sans doute une nouvelle étape importante
dans la lutte contre les maladies
génétiques des chercheurs français ont
enrayé la progression de la myopathie
chez des souris
ça confirme les travaux qui sont menés
depuis quelques mois déjà
jean daniel flaysakier une bonne
nouvelle pour des souris qui est en même
pas une bonne nouvelle pour des hommes
en effet ces petites souris n'y a pas
deux vont bien et pourtant leurs muscles
étaient dans un triste état à cause de
la maladie
il aurait dû normalement avoir un aspect
beaucoup plus reluisant comme ici parce
que ce muscle normale lui contient une
substance indispensable à son
fonctionnement
la dystrophine et des chercheurs
français dirigée par axel kahn à michel
peiry codé rue une bonne idée puisqu'il
manquait de la dystrophine eh bien on
allait essayer d'en faire fabriquer pour
cela ils ont pris le gène qui fabrique
normalement la dystrophine l'ont mis
dans un adénovirus c'est à dire le virus
responsable de nos banal ou de gorge et
ont ensuite injecté le tout dans le
muscle des petites souris plus de six
mois après l'injection
le muscle fonctionne bien grâce à la
dystrophine qu'il produit des résultats
agréable pour la souris est encore plus
prometteur pour la thérapie génique chez
l'être humain